Just the other day,
the partners at my firm pulled me aside
and they were visibly upset
about something that I had done.
A portion of this video
sponsored by Vessey.
More on them later in this video.
You made a decision
that we can all agree on
and you were not being transparent
about this.
Honestly,
I did speak to everyone individually.
Hey, guys.
My name's Dami, and I'm an architect
in beautiful Vancouver, B.C..
When I got that feedback, I cried.
No, I'm just kidding.
I had a lot of bad emotions.
You know, I had done my version
of what I thought was right.
And it really felt
like I was being accused
of being a bad architect
and even a dishonest person.
As I kind of progress into my career.
And also,
as I kind of built my YouTube business,
I've been getting criticism of all kinds,
including ones like this.
And it's
been really challenging to manage.
So lately I've been learning a lot about
how to deal with criticism
and feedback more effectively.
So today I want to talk about some of
the things that I learned from the book.
Thanks for the feedback.
In the first part of the video,
I'm going to talk about how to receive
that feedback.
And the second part of the video, I'm
going to talk about how to navigate that
feedback conversation and how to implement
that feedback into your lives.
And in the atrium, this is where you have
your communal gatherings.
It's a pretty model, but
I don't think you're quite
capturing the essence of the library
as an institution, given
the ontology of the library.
You know, a library is an institution
of culture and history.
And you expect people
to just sit around here like that.
Handling
feedback on your project is one thing
and handling feedback on your performance
or your voice.
That's a whole nother thing.
And in fact,
it is really important for you
to categorize
the different types of criticism.
So there's three types of feedback.
There's evaluation.
That's
where you talk about where you stand
in relation to the expectations
and to other people.
There's coaching or advice,
which is all about helping you improve,
and I think a crit or like a performance
review is probably somewhere
in between those two.
There's also appreciation or recognition
or things which basically lets
you know that you're doing well
and that your efforts are being noticed.
So when you're asking for feedback,
you actually want to be fairly clear
on what you're looking for just to prevent
confusion or conflict from both parties.
The hardest part about receiving feedback
is actually the emotional response,
and it's the emotional response
which makes us angry or defensive.
And a lot of the times
we can get dismissive of that feedback.
But if you identify what triggers
those emotional responses,
you can have much better control
over those reactions.
Dealing with criticism
can take a toll on you.
For me, whenever I feel overwhelmed,
I like to go outside
and spend some time in nature.
But sometimes we don't always have dry
weather or dry land.
That's why today
I want to talk to you about Vesey.
Vesey shoes are 100% waterproof.
They're stylish and comfortable,
so you can wear them wherever you go.
It's made from denim attacks,
which is a dual climate material
that keeps you cool in the heat
and warm in the cold.
But the best part is it really
doesn't feel like the kind of shoes
I'll be waterproof.
They're super comfy. They hug my feet.
They're extremely lightweight
and they're breathable.
I love how I can wear them
all season around,
and I literally wear them everywhere.
These are the only pair of shoes
I need to pack,
and they're so versatile and functional.
And if you're someone who lives in a rainy
climate, Vasey is a great investment
in your closet.
Get $25 off for each pair at VSI dot
com slash demi-leigh.
Generally there's three types of triggers.
There's the truth triggers.
So truth triggers
our responses to feedback
we feel is wrong or unhelpful or unfair.
But as we know,
everyone has their own idea of the truth.
So the very, very
first thing you want to do is instead of
thinking, No, that's wrong, or, Oh, well,
that makes sense for you, but not for me.
You have to acknowledge that everyone
thinks differently, and even if it's hard,
try to ask yourself like what is right
about what the other person's saying.
At the same time, try to examine yourself
for any blindspots in your thinking.
There's behavior patterns.
So we often have behaviors
that are totally unknown to us.
But others B.S. it really clearly.
A really good example is using filler
words like
ums or Oz or like
like that,
because they've been so embedded
into your speech pattern that you don't
even recognize how you do it.
And for me,
I only recognize that I do it a lot.
When I started making videos on YouTube
and another blind spot is typically like
you judged your actions
by the intent and others
and judge your actions on impact
and especially how it impacts them.
And paradoxically,
when we come into challenging situations,
we tend to attribute it
to the circumstance.
But other people tend
to connect it to our character.
So it's come to my attention by you
made a decision
on the glazing frame colors
that we can all agree on, and you were not
being transparent about this.
And if this keeps happening,
this is the fastest way
we're going to lose trust in you.
I had to make that call.
I was already so late
on getting back to them and I couldn't
wait another week for us to all meet
and honestly,
I did speak to everyone individually
and my understanding
from the conversation was that
we were all aligned on picking white.
We also have tells
that we might not be aware of like
facial expressions or voice
and any other,
like nonverbal behaviors or like habits
that can say the opposite thing
of your intentions.
There's also emotional distortion
when our emotional reaction to something
is like way out of proportion
to the content of the feedback.
You can find some of these blind spots
by observing
how you get really defensive
or recording yourself.
You can also look for patterns
in the feedback, like if you're getting
the same feedback from different people,
you know that's an issue.
And the second type of trigger
is relationship triggers, which is
an emotional response to the person
more than the content of the feedback.
So there's two main types of relationship
triggers.
One is our opinion of that person.
So when we get negative feedback,
we are subconsciously
looking for ways to disqualify that person
from giving that feedback.
And then number two is how they treat us.
So if you feel like
they're not appreciating you
or your efforts or you feel like
they don't have the authority
or you you might just feel like that
person doesn't really like you.
And in situations
like this, a very common response
can be for us to respond with something
that's like
aimed at the person
rather than the issue itself.
And when this happens,
it will split the conversation into.
And you just start talking
about two completely different things.
So, for example, your roommate will say,
oh, you're so messy
and you'll say something like, Oh, yeah,
but you're so loud.
Like, you leave the TV on till 2 a.m.
and I can never sleep.
And so it's very important for you
to recognize this and actually address
each one of these topics separately
before they turn into bigger problems.
And sometimes the conflict
might not even be happening
because of you or the other person,
but because we're all a part of the system
that defines our relationship.
And you might have different
values or habits
and you might have different roles
in the relationship.
So sometimes just like stepping back
and like looking at the whole system
as a whole can be really helpful.
The next one is identity triggers,
and these ones are a big one.
Identity triggers can happen
when the feedback doesn't align
with your sense of who you are
or the story that you tell about yourself.
For me, like when I got that feedback
from my bosses,
a part of the reason why it stung so much
was because it was an identity trigger.
I felt
like it was an attack on my integrity
and my capability as a person
and as an architect.
And, you know, I consider myself
to be a very transparent person.
And that's kind of one of the things
that I take a lot of pride in.
And so my emotional response
was probably kind
of exaggerated
compared to the issue at hand.
And I think the best way to deal with
identity triggers
is just like adopting a growth mindset.
A person with a growth mindset
sees their traits
as evolving.
But if you have a fixed mindset,
you will see your abilities as stable
and finished.
And there's actually a ways
you can develop a growth mindset
by listening to feedback as coaching
rather than evaluation or judgment.
It's more about like
how you're doing things
and what you're doing rather than on you.
Also, don't worry so much about how
this is affecting the other person's
opinion of you.
You know, in the end, it's really hard
to change people's opinion of you,
but it's really easy for you to change
how you reflect on yourself.
So just try to focus on that.
Also, whenever you get feedback,
try to evaluate yourself
on how you're taking that feedback.
Like if you can handle that feedback
better than others,
then appreciate yourself for that
because that in itself
is a really positive trait
that actually very few people have.
Identity triggers are probably one
of the most emotional out of all of these.
So try to monitor your emotional reactions
thoughtfully
by trying to control your emotions,
or even better, like trying
to separate your emotions from the facts.
I also have my own kind
of strange strategy for this.
So whenever I'm in a bad situation
or I get bad feedback,
I imagine myself as like a character
in a comedy movie
or in a sitcom,
and I just kind of proceed
to deal with the issue at hand.
Yes, it is important
to adopt a growth mindset.
But there are certain things
that are just like
outside of your control,
like how others feel about you,
and especially after you do your best
to remedy the situation.
If they still have a negative
feeling towards you,
just let it go
and just try to be sad about it
because it's a waste of your time
and your energy
to keep thinking about things
that are outside of your control.
Now that we've identified the triggers
and we kind of understand
how to control them,
how do we navigate those conversations
and get the most out of that feedback?
Douglas Stone defines
three phases of a feedback
conversation
the open, the body and the close.
The open is before the content
of the feedback.
It's where you get aligned
with the other person
by trying to understand
what kind of feedback is this
and what's the intent behind
this feedback?
Is this evaluation? Is this coaching?
Is this appreciation?
And also trying to understand
who has the final word
and is this feedback negotiable?
If you're working for someone,
your boss in most cases has a final word.
No matter how right you think you are.
In the end,
it does kind of come down to this.
You are there by choice.
You know, you agreed to the deal.
You work for them and they are paying you
to represent the firm.
And obviously,
there's a lot of nuance to this,
but that's the kind of systems framework
that you have to consider.
And then there's the body.
The body is the content of the feedback
or like the meat of the talk.
And to get the most out of this feedback,
you need to listen.
That's something that I'm really,
really trying to work on.
Try to really pay attention
to what the other person's saying.
And while you're doing this,
listen to your own internal voice
and try to watch for the triggers
that we talked about.
And then clarify,
you can always ask for specificities
or specifics
on expectations or consequence.
And you can also add your own input
and try to explain the situation
in your own thoughts
and in your observations.
You can also talk
about your interpretations on things
or your feelings.
You can also try to referee
the conversation.
Try to diagnose and describe
the communication problems as they come up
so that you can kind of propose solutions
in a real time.
And the last stage of that is the clothes.
That's where you clarify the commitments
and expectations and the follow up.
You know who's going to do what
specifically when you leave the meeting?
Are there like benchmarks or consequences
if you don't meet those benchmarks?
And are you going to be having
regular check ins?
Then the last but the most important step
is actually incorporating the feedback.
Try to focus on one thing at a time or,
you know, tested it
with small experiments and make sure
you really, really understand
what the other person's trying to see.
You can give yourself rewards
for making these changes,
or you can also add consequences
for not making these changes.
Also, try to make the other person
feel valued by taking their advice
and later,
they are going to come to you for advice.
In conclusion.
What's interesting,
but also really true, is that
negative feedback,
if you know how to handle it,
it can actually have a much more positive
impact on your life than positive impact.
Think about an architecture project.
If you get really, really positive
feedback, then at the end of the day,
it's kind of hard
to know where to take that.
But when you have a really bad crit,
you might cry.
But you have so many different ways
you can take your project afterwards.
Right?
So try to really use this feedback
to your advantage
and really make something of it.
All right, guys.
So I hope that was helpful.
Let me know
if you have any comments or questions
or if you have any strategies
for dealing with negative feedback.
If you like this video,
please give me a thumbs up.
And if you like this type of content,
subscribe to the channel.
I'm always making videos once every week.
Also, I have a Discord Channel.
If you want to pop in there
and ask questions,
it's full of students and professionals
from all over the world.
And yeah, with
I'll see you guys in the next video, bye!.